.
>> Laura: THANK YOU BOTH
TONIGHT, SO IMPORTANT.
LAST NIGHT OF THE ANGLE EXPLAIN
TO THE CURRENT DESTRUCTION OF
OUR ECONOMY, OUR SCHOOLS, EVEN
OUR SUPERPOWER STATUS, THAT IS
THE DEMOCRATS ACTUAL INTENDED TO
GOAL.
THEY HAVE COME TO DESPISE
AMERICA, OUR TRADITIONS, OUR
HERITAGE, OUR HISTORY.
THEY HAVE DISDAIN FOR OUR
CONSTITUTION AND BELIEVE OUR
FOUNDING WAS ILLEGITIMATE.
THEY BELIEVE OUR FOUNDERS WERE
UNABASHEDLY RACIST.
THE GOAL IS SIMPLE.
A LEVELING OF THE OLD AMERICA IN
ORDER TO CREATE SOMETHING NEW, A
NEW ORDER THAT GIVES THEM ALL
THE MONEY AND ALL THE POWER.
MOST PEOPLE WON'T VOLUNTARILY
CHOOSE A LOWER STANDARD OF
LIVING IN LESS FREEDOM, THE LEFT
KNOWS THIS RADICAL CHANGE MUST
BE FORCED ON THE PEOPLE.
THIS IS BEING DONE THROUGH FAKE
EMERGENCIES, PHONY SELF
GENERATED CRISES.
THEY CITE CLIMATE CHANGE TO
JUSTIFY THE RAPID PHASEOUT OF
GAS POWERED CARS AND THE BANNING
OF GAS APPLIANCES AND THE
CANCELLATION OF PERMIT LEASES
FOR OIL DRILLING.
THEY CITE A SYSTEMIC RACISM TO
JUSTIFY THEIR NEW TWISTED SCHOOL
CURRICULA AND THEIR DEI DICTATED
CORPORATE HIRING PRACTICES.
THEY POINT TO AMORPHOUS DOMESTIC
THREATS TO JUSTIFY PARTNERING
WITH SOCIAL MEDIA GIANTS TO
MODERATE ONLINE CONTENT WHICH OF
COURSE JUST MEANS BANNING
OPPOSING POLITICAL VIEWS.
TODAY'S DEMOCRATS WILL ALWAYS
HAVE A REASON TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
MONEY AND YOUR FREEDOM AND THEY
FOUND THEIR NEW MODEL FOR WHAT
THIS NEW AMERICA SHOULD LOOK
LIKE.
CAN YOU GUESS WHAT IT IS?
GO WEST, MY FRIENDS, GO WEST TO
CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF DREAMING HAPPENING
ANYMORE.
IT'S HARD TO FIND A STATE THAT
IS MORE SCREWED UP THAN THE ONCE
GOLDEN STATE WHICH OF COURSE
MAKES IT THE LOGICAL EXEMPLAR
FOR THE SCREWED UP
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
OF COURSE CALIFORNIA STILL HAS
ITS NATURAL BEAUTY AND AMAZING
POTENTIAL BUT THE DEMOCRATS
SUPER MAJORITY RUNNING THE PLACE
HAS REALLY DONE A NUMBER ON IT.
AFTER THEY DECLARED THEMSELVES A
SANCTUARY FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, THEY ALSO BECAME A
SANCTUARY FOR CRIMINALS,
FREELOADERS, DRUG ADDICTS, THE
HOMELESS, AND NOW THEY ARE
ADDING SOMETHING NEW TO THE MIX.
LATE LAST NIGHT
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM SIGNED A
LAW THAT WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA A
SAFE HAVEN FOR FAMILIES WHO WANT
TO MUTILATE THEIR CHILDREN WITH
TRANSIT SURGERIES AND OTHER
TREATMENTS.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
WHEN GAS IS BACK UP AT $6 A
GALLON IN CALIFORNIA, THIS IS
WHAT GAVIN NEWSOM'S
PRIORITIES --
ONE HOMELESS ARE CAMPED OUT IN
EVERY MUNICIPAL PARK IN THE
STATE, THIS IS WHAT THEIR
PRIORITY IS.
WHEN CRIME IS SKYROCKETING UP
AND DOWN THE STATE, THIS IS WHAT
THEIR PRIORITY IS.
YES, THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
MODERN LEFT WANTS FOR THE REST
OF AMERICA.
A GOVERNMENT THAT FORCES CHANGE
ON THE VOTERS, NOT ONE THAT
SERVES THE VOTERS.
I WANT YOU TO KEEP ALL OF THIS
IN MIND WHEN YOU VOTE IN THE
MIDTERMS.
JOINING ME NOW IS KEVIN KILEY,
CALIFORNIA STATE REP AND
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I HAVE SUCH GREAT AFFECTION FOR
CALIFORNIA, I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA BAR I LIVED OUT THERE
FOR A WHILE AS A YOUNG ASSOCIATE
AT A LAW FIRM AND I SPENT A LOT
OF TIME IN CALIFORNIA, A LOT OF
FAMILY THERE.
IS CALIFORNIA AND THE MODEL?
SHOULD BE THE MODEL FOR THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY?
>> GAVIN NEWSOM THINKS SO AND
THANKS FOR HAVING ME TONIGHT.
HE SAID AGAIN AND AGAIN
CALIFORNIA IS A MODEL FOR THE
NATION AND WHAT YOU JUST SAID,
CALIFORNIA HAS SO MUCH GOING FOR
IT, I LOVE CALIFORNIA HAD A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE LEAVING LOVE
CALIFORNIA TOO.
THEY JUST HATE THE POLITICS.
YOU MENTIONED HOW IT'S ALL ABOUT
CONTROL AND IT REMINDED ME OF
WHAT GAVIN NEWSOM SAID ON
APRIL 1ST OF 2020, THIS WAS LESS
THAN A MONTH IN TO THE WHOLE
COVID SITUATION.
HE SAID THIS WAS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR A NEW PROGRESSIVE ERA,
OPPORTUNITY TO RESHAPE THE WAY
WE DO BUSINESS IN THE WAY WE
GOVERN, HE SAID THAT OUT LOUD
AND THIS WAS A CHANCE JUST FAST
FORWARD HIS ENTIRE PROGRESSIVE
PROJECT WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT
JUST HAPPENS.
FOR 170 STRAIGHT YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAD A GROWING
POPULATION BUT UNDER
GAVIN NEWSOM FOR THE LAST TWO
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER OUR
POPULATION HAS DECLINED.
>> Laura: CALIFORNIA WHEN I
WAS GROWING UP IN THE 1980s
AND 90s, CALIFORNIA WAS THE
PLACE PEOPLE WANTED TO MOVE TO.
NOW IT'S THE PLACE PEOPLE WANT
TO MOVE FROM.
THAT DYNAMIC ALONE SPELLS DOOM
FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
I MENTIONED THIS IS HOW
GAVIN NEWSOM SPEND HIS NEW
TRANSGENDER BILL.
HE SAID WE BELIEVE NO ONE SHOULD
BE PROSECUTED FOR GETTING THE
CARE THEY NEED, PARENTS KNOWS
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR KIDS, THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE DECISIONS
AND HELP THEIR CHILDREN WITHOUT
FEAR.
THIS IS A PHONY ISSUE, HOW DO
THEY POSSIBLY CLAIM TO STAND FOR
PARENTAL CHOICE WHEN IT'S ALL
ABOUT SIDESTEPPING THE PARENTS
AND A SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA?
>> THERE IS NO STATE IN THE
COUNTRY THAT ERODES THE RIGHTS
OF PARENTS MORE THAN CALIFORNIA
DOES.
THIS IS SO TYPICAL.
THIS IS A HORRIBLE -- THEY ARE
TAKING KIDS AWAY FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
CALIFORNIA IS THE STRATEGY OF
POLITICIANS LIKE GAVIN NEWSOM TO
PROMOTE THESE CARTOON INITIALLY
WOKE POLICIES AS A WAY TO COVER
UP WHAT'S REALLY HAPPENING TO
OUR STATE.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING TO
CALIFORNIA WE LEAD THE NATION
AND ALL THE WRONG WAYS.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST GROUP OF
POVERTY, WE HAVE OUT-OF-CONTROL
CRIME.
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS IN OUR
SCHOOLS ARE BIGGER THAN ANYWHERE
IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY TRY TO HAVE THIS WOKE
CARTOON INITIALLY PROGRESSIVE
AGENDA TO TAKE ATTENTION AWAY
FROM ALL OF THAT.
PEOPLE ARE NOT FOOLED, WE ARE
SEEING PEOPLE LEAVE THE STATES
RIGHT NOW IN RECORD NUMBERS AND
LIKE YOU SAID CALIFORNIA USED TO
BE THE STATE WHERE ANYONE COULD
GET A HEAD TO.
IT WAS THE FULL REALIZATION OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM AND NOW IF
THE STATES THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
CAN'T WAIT TO LEAVE BEHIND.
>> Lau